yo in this video I'm gonna talk about
the seven basic style rules that every
guy should know let's not waste any more
time let's get right into hey if you're
new here to my channel welcome I'm
Daniel consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next deals now
let's start with the first basic rule
that every guy should know dress
according to who you are and what you
stand for you always have the choice to
dress how you want but remember people
will always judge you based on your
appearance you know that saying where
they say don't judge a book by it's
cover well unfortunately most people out
there they still do it so they will make
assumptions on who you are based on the
way that you dress so don't overdress
don't under dress just dress yourself
according to who you are according to
what fits well with you in this way you
are letting people know who you are
before you even say would know your
measurements we all have different body
types
right and that general small medium or
large it's not gonna look the same on
everybody because that's just the
general size some people have broader
shoulders some guys have bigger arms
some guys have bigger lads so it will
look different so you have to know your
measurements if you know your
measurements then you'll know better
what kind of clothes will fit you and
look good on you you can also then find
a good tailor if you find a good tailor
they can make the clothes to fit you
perfectly and that'll just improve your
appearance immensely don't buy clothes
that you like buy clothes that you love
and that you use all the time in this
way you save money you don't buy
unnecessary stuff that you don't need
but you can invest that same money on
the items that you really love and
really need so you buy better quality
clothing there's a lot of videos out
there that says these are the clothes
you need you need this you mean that you
this you don't need all the stuff you
just need the basic clothing essentials
I thought of my list pre-interview
description down below if you want to go
and check it out every guy needs to know
how to tie a tie this is very basic when
it comes to style but I'm very surprised
with this a lot of guys out there that
had no clue they have no clue how to tie
it's high if you're still young chances
are you'll find yourself in a situation
very soon where you will need to know
how to tie a tie
alright how quick you're gonna show you
how to tie a tie
specifically a Windsor knot because
that's the most easiest one to tie
alright so when you look at the time you
got to ins you get it and then you got a
thicket
not that complicated now what you want
to do is bring the thinning up to around
here right now the first step of tying a
tie is to take this in and bring it
underneath the long stick in right step
two you take the long thick end bring it
underneath these two and bring it over
and back to a Ross so let's do that
under right through these two and back
to where you owe us
alright now this these two things are
very important because they keep the
whole thing together the whole time take
the thick end you bring it underneath
this whole not area and you bring it
over and back - it was alright so let's
do that under and over - to where it was
right last step you want to bring this
whole thick end and you're ready bring
it under through these two and then it's
gonna be a loop and you put it through
the loop so there's 15 pack okay so go
it's gonna go
under through these two and then through
the loop all right there we go and now
what you have to do is take this and
tighten it a little bit
adjust it adjust it take this whole thin
end and you hold it and then you take
the knot area and you bring it up like
that now you can adjust this part here
until you feel very comfortable with it
all right bring the color down okay now
you have to adjust you're gonna just
leave it like this right so you have to
adjust a little bit all right it's not
perfect not but now you know how to tie
and knot
get some practicing and you'll get it
done all right let's move on
[Music]
every man needs to know how to choose
the right shoes for every occasion
for example Oxford Derby or loafers look
good and work or at business meetings
leather boots and loafers sandals those
are great for casual situations like
socializing and depending on the weather
sneakers and chucks they're good for
everyday use there are also different
types of a specific shoe style let's
look at boots for example you get boots
for work
hiking casual and smart sucks if you
wear socks in such a way where people
can see it it can either make or break
your clothing style if you want to stay
safe remember these following rules for
white socks wear it mainly with athletic
shoes then monotone socks are for dress
shoes and the color of your socks should
match the color of your suit pants and
if you wear shorts put hidden socks on
unless you're going to the gym know your
basic color combinations if you know
which colors go together if you wear
your outfits it can greatly enhance the
look of your style so let me explain it
very quickly almost all the colors look
really good with black and white colors
that fit well with beige are black brown
red and green navy blue with white beige
yellow red and green yellow with black
brown sky blue and navy blue orange with
white yellow black and dark green brown
with white beige black red and dark
green dark green with white beige
sky blue yellow navy blue and black red
with white beige sky blue navy blue
black and brown sky blue looks good with
brown dark green dark purple red and
beige purple with white beige sky blue
pink blue and brown if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers
[Music]